consumer debt is rising consumer
spending is rising and we also are on
fears of a recession looming later this
year and currently happening right now
so we're just gonna go through a little
bit uh consumer spending rose in april
and incomes also rose in april but
consumer spending was up 0.9 percent in
april that may not seem like a big deal
but when we look at it on a large time
frame it's a pretty big deal consumers
are taking on more and more debt
their expenses are increasing more and
more and more they're spending a lot on
non-discretionary products like consumer
products um and then also interest rates
are rising stocks are falling right so
we're in a bad time for consumers right
now um and then
was it the average household debt
balance increased by 266 or the
aggregate excuse me increased by 266
billion in the first quarter that's a
1.7 rise from just last quarter so debt
is rising very very rapidly um for the
average day consumer
and then balances now stand at almost 16
trillion dollars which is 1.7 trillion
higher than before the pandemic at the
end of 2019 so clearly consumers have
just taken more and more debt you can
see a large
portion of that debt has been mortgages
over time right so this chart goes all
the way back to 2003 and you can see how
much mortgages uh were
being originated then and you can see
that we are actually at higher or
greater levels now um and also obviously
consumer debt has just increased a lot
over time
student loans going up too
headed north
look at that 10 now of all uh of all
total debt is student loans that's an
interesting chart for sure i mean the
the mortgage stuff makes sense oh we
have uh originations by credit score
here too so they are uh obviously uh
giving out more money the people with
the high credit score it seems uh 760
plus but even uh it's interesting to see
that percentage get increased so much
right
wait where seven six like i'm just
talking about like look how many people
or how much money with higher credit
scores are probably taking out bigger
loans right not only on a quantity basis
but uh uh
the the size of the loan then the credit
score at origination 50th percentile
your score is above between 750 and 800
25th percentile if your score is 700 or
750
650 to 700 is the 10th percentile this
makes me feel like the housing market
isn't in that bad of shape why because
when you look at 2005 2008 um you can
see that the loans that were being
originated were two people with
a lot lower scores yeah i don't
necessarily think people are saying that
it's out of uh out of shape from a uh
like the quality standpoint your ability
to earn income uh back then they were
basically giving loans to anyone who who
wanted one subprime
yeah and i think now the problem is too
that the home prices are rising too
quickly there's private equity firms
that are buying up a lot of homes right
which is another big problem because uh
now everything's turning into rentals so
there's an area of uh like a pocket of
homes that used to be for the middle
class family that you would go you'd
make your money over 20 year 30-year
career buy this home you'd live in it
for the rest of your life and you and
that would be your thing those homes are
getting taken off the market right and
then the cost to build a new home and
the ability to do it quickly has also
changed which changes the whole housing
market now because the top of the market
has gone up tremendously the middle of
the market is being bought up by private
equity firms who are going to rent them
back to you
uh so they're the whole idea right is
like the the american dream is uh is
disappearing because of that and i think
there's probably some truth to that but
i think the biggest concern out of all
three of those is is the rising home
prices now because uh average homes i
believe are over 500k now median home is
over 400k or slightly above in the
united states so
that's pretty bad like that's a lot of
money the way i put it is the average
american can't afford the average home
right now